Penguins men present the one with a
pearl with a pearl yeah I believe that's
how they find it they find like a pearl
or something that's how they propose to
their ladies really yup I think so wow
bring that up
I'm pretty sure I believe it's a pearl
they definitely find something I was
watching an animal show one time and
they like went to the end of the Earth
to find their thing to present their
lady I think you're watching maybe Ice
Age or something
I think it's something like that using a
pearl to propose I think so because I'm
not seeing anything on that maybe not a
pearl but definitely something like they
have to find something and then give it
to the lady I'm pretty sure how do
penguins propose to one another
Pebbles sorry a less fancy Pearl it's a
very good point that's all a pebble is
dude yeah a pebble is just a pearl it's
the smoothest pebble
isn't that nice romance people think
romance is dead huh that's a good point
isn't it during courtship a male penguin
will find the smoothest Pebble to give
to a female as a gift if she likes the
offering she'll place it in the nest and
the two will continue building up their
little Pebble mound in preparation for
the eggs that's actually beautiful I
didn't know that that yeah I've been
crying right now I didn't know that that
was their beginning of the foundation
for their nest for their eggs that's
[__] cute
dude that is so romantic it's romantic
because first of all to even be a
penguin right and balance a little
Pebble yeah and they don't it's like
they look down at Pebbles there they
gotta go find the smoothest Pebble yeah
and first of all how do you even lift
the pebble further because you can
barely even look down I don't think a
penguin so you have to almost get the
pebble way up here look at it maybe kick
it yes but then how do you test if it's
the smoothest oh
how about that
penguins are wild look at the one of
them giving it to the other one with the
Beak he gives it I think it's like When
Harry Met Sally
yeah
man that's some that's amazing
is there something else really romantic
that happens in nature see if you can
find some some of Nature's best romance
because the only other thing I've seen
is that lizard that guy who's like a
total perv that like
puts like the big fake yeah that's the
only other thing I was gonna say as well
there was I'm pretty sure in one of
those shows I was watching one time I
think it was some sort of a bird he
literally put on uh like I show you
think you dance s performance like you
literally
it was unbelievable he looked like
it looked like Chris Brown he was crazy
it did
and then I think he actually
so it really had a but he really popped
off on the day it's a lot of sea Brown
it was beautiful
flamingos dance for their love take us
through that Zach yeah there's a this
article is a couple examples but
Flamingo stands for their love I guess
in separate groups
um they struck together in search of a
mate seahorses I guess flirt a lot horny
um yeah
wolves
wolves made for life
now that's interesting wolves mate for
life yeah their packs are generally like
nuclear families that comprise an adult
male oh damn dude did you possibly see
that um that story out of Vegas about a
month or two ago that some sort of dog I
think it was not it wasn't a bulldog I
think it was maybe a pit bull was
adopted by a pack of wolves outside of
Vegas and became their leader really
yeah damn Animal Control found him and
took him back but he became their leader
he was the leader of the pack wow they
didn't kill him and then let him become
the leader
huh yeah white dogs
rescued apparently he became the leader
of the crew wow
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one